[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
2019 ball chess classic we are your
hosts for this event my name is Caleb
Denby and I'm joined by the wonderful
Grandmaster Dennis ball and we are
giving you the commentary overall of the
very exciting games in this event and
we're only one day in but already things
have been split wide open in the a group
a lot of things have happened and we
actually have two clear leaders so why
don't we take a look at the standings so
Ferrando Kumi an invasive dura bali are
the winners from round one so they now
share first place those were both very
interesting games I think Massif
defeated Ilyas Mira in a pretty
interesting opening line and it's a very
little idea yeah very recent idea from
dubov also interesting how front beat he
Pato mm-hmm and it was like a long
theoretical struggle there Malcolm young
turn out to know way more yeah it's
Turkish competitor welcoming and
actually winning with the black pieces
and round one so we'll see what these
players do today following them are a
myriad of players all tied for the third
place position with the draw in the
first rounds and of course rounding out
the a group is Alex epitope and Elias
mirin the victims of round one now let's
check out the B group so the B group had
an insane first round with decisive all
decisive games that is correct and the
number one seed manuel Petrosyan did
manage to win his games so i guess if
you had to pick a favorite I would
probably go with him also tied with him
for first place is yes Eric asada Perez
around poco bian Jackson Bullock and
Steven xeric it's important to mention
that this is the second GM who's a
yasser yeah yes that's true not the yes
acero and we're all familiar with but
a very strong grandmaster in his own
right also he's the little brother of
Quezada Unni a seafarers who earn a
champion here before yes absolutely and
why don't we take a look at the format
of this tournament that these players
are playing in it's a pretty interesting
one there are 210 player round-robin so
that's your a group and your B group
both groups play a complete round robin
in the time control for the games is 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and then
they get 30 minutes added on past move
40 for the remainder of the game there
is also a 30 second increment for move 1
and another interesting rule for this
tournament is that no draw offers are
allowed before blacks thirtieth move
these players have to make it to at
least move 30 before turning into the
Sinquefield cups of moves I don't think
there's there's any danger of that rule
of really coming into effect here after
round 1 with those 5 decisive games in
Group B and all of those interesting
games in Group A as well be sure to join
us online you can follow the game to
yourself at us chess champs calm can
join us on YouTube where we'll be
keeping an eye on the chat I wanna say a
quick hello to the wonderful viewers
Peter Larson Grinchy harsh gin doll and
hashtag thank you all for watching hash
tag personally yeah just just hash tag
is in the chance to join a wonderful
stuff you can also join us on twitter
using the hash tag fall chess classic
with that in mind why don't we just go
ahead and take a look at the pairings
for today all the players up there still
hard at work in the tournament hall in
Group A we have ray Robson squaring off
against Doris routes
Elias Marin looking to get looking to
come back stronger in round 2 against
Jordan fun forest olexander bortnik has
drawn his game against Alex epitaph and
Frant Malcolm Yan one of the leaders is
playing against Alexander Lenderman with
the white pieces and then lastly our key
matchup of the day vara Cobian is
squaring off against the deceived herb
ollie
again one of the tournament leaders and
these two have actually played each
other before there is some history there
if you're a grudge match yeah if you're
a fan of the summer chess classic you
might remember that var and
volley actually had tied for first in a
previous summer classic played a big big
tiebreak match which was Agron felt may
have it whole games groom felt same
colors they repeated true
Karpov Kasparov style and guess what
opening we have today it looks like a
grin felt that's Curtis in that in that
tie break the Seif was actually the one
to come out victorious winning two to
zero in the tiebreak now let's see if
bar can uh make some improvements
actually managed to win the gun fell
game and the tiebreaker yeah I'm very
impressive stuff so what's going on in
this game Dennis what do we have so we
have the classical Greenfeld setup that
is known since the kramnik Kasparov
match of course thousand London this is
the typical position and previously on
the a Kobe under our belly matches Queen
d2 was assayed knight c6 takes takes
after rook b1 maybe even rooks e1 was
also played and it turned out to be an
equal position with draw belly
eventually winning and the tire breaks
even though the classical game ended in
a draw right so it turns out that a
Cobian decided to diverge with Knight B
- interesting this is a very nice little
funky move the idea being if you take
the pawn I have this nice little jump
then I'll show it to you takes then
bye-bye little lady because a trap it
was always a trap
very nice creature and so so black
really needs to react all right often
they go ninety seven or Bishop d7 ninety
some is a little passive it does block
in this Bishop so it's not that popular
mm-hmm Bishop d7 is more popular
and back in the old days when there
weren't straw rules right we would
suspect the draw incoming ah but Nidal
Israel not seen is the most critical
line yes it takes something white does
when he doesn't want to uh yes much and
sometimes when you are really
aggressively wanting to draw you
withdraw the bishop back attack the
Queen it has no other square than going
back and repetition that would get the
job done so but what was bars choice
though in fact what Steve decided to
take on d4 Wow
Knight c4 we already seen this nice
little Queen trap and it's no different
even if the pawn is black on people so
Queen d8 takes castle here usually f5
was played before but somehow had kind
of gone out of fashion in fact this d5
sacrifice is pretty interesting if
you're a grünfeld player you would never
dare to meet that rook on a1 cause it's
like a poison apple and if you read grim
tales you know how that ends well she
ends up okay okay but not so much here
but in a hint side maybe he shouldn't
have tried that up yeah but the dark
squares are far too weak it's just too
weak and the bishop is just ready to
enter the fray that's very nice for
white so they're usually after d5 their
Castle Bishop d4 and because of this d5
pawn which is protected Mike is slightly
better here right so the Rob le decided
to castle rock c1 f5 now mean b3 and
Bishop e6 and this is typical Greenfeld
play don't don't run away from me come
back come back
okay might have smell fresh let me
refresh this
okay so we're back to Bishop e6 so the
point is I'm willing to give up pawns
for active play right also if white is
not careful I might just start picking
up all your pawns and if I remain active
or maybe just Bishop d4 remain active
and with equal amount of material black
will actually be better yeah this is the
classic Greenfeld style right
you play our activity and challenge the
center yes the Bishop e6 is and always
in Broomfield spirit 97 the idea is to
immediately challenged white species
also notice this queen is a little bit
out of place
Queen a6 so that's why a coab young
probably decided to move the Queen away
mmm
it also tagged the bishop on e6 96 d5
Bishop f7 and this is a typical Grunfeld
situation but it's up pawns but is
lacking in development right it's an f1
who moves to Castle yes and that kind of
reminds me what Carlson said at the sink
though Cup can you recall what he said
about castling I do not recall so but he
said if you have one move to Castle
mm-hmm you have you have the luxury you
can feel confident that you're gonna
make it right if you have to that's
interesting there's some hope that you
can castle 3 forget it you're done it's
over so war is I guess he's got some
hopes to yes so he's 2 moves away from
castle links so Markovian definitely has
hope for castling all right Knight takes
takes Queen takes b6 this is the other
way of kind of releasing the tension
right offering up some trees a Cobian
offers the Queen trades hoping that the
initiative dissolves takes takes rook F
b8 and I cannot praise this move enough
you're not really wanting to take pawns
you
active pieces and damn pawns absolutely
rupee eight should be three Bishop b2 so
what black is playing for is quick
attack on the king before I cook castle
yeah and if black manages a Kobe on will
be in slight trouble I'm not saying that
he'd be lost right but he would
definitely be under pressure
even though up upon because these pawns
will eventually fall prey to all these
active pieces it's definitely so they
should be too how does black kind of or
how does white kind of activate his
pieces here before it all goes wrong so
white vini needs to be careful yeah one
mistake and you're done like even rooks
II to hear what already be kind of dicey
because rookie wants stuff like Bishop
e2 root K one I collect everything and
take a look what it actually ends up
down the pond down the pond and you
can't move either its stuff it's
unfortunate so that's that's a good part
of the grim felt that you might
eventually end up up upon the active
pieces right so look the one this is
more accurate kind of preparing Bishop
d2 at Bishop c3 and that's what happened
takes sakes will be one check and bars
turn here at yes
so if Brooke d1 the issue is again you
can't really move your Bishop anywhere
because I'll check you and take your
rook right so this can get sad yeah I I
kind of still believe in virus position
yeah for example if I can just I'm not
saying the bar is better but I don't
think he should lose this game right he
can find some way to look at a suit on
definitely defendable like XV comes into
mind who takes takes I'm actually
considering just walking up with my king
yeah that seems reasonable to me
maybe I'll just play King e1
and rook g1 and I'm gonna get out I'm
you're gonna get out I'm gonna get out
okay I'm trying my best Bishop e2 oh my
I want to break free Dennis you really
want to break free yeah Bishop um mm
maybe King up to here do you have to
yeah I guess I'm going down upon all of
a sudden I mean you have g4 but I kind
of feeling that this will be the end my
friend the end I didn't really break
free I guess you didn't know I tried I
tried my best on yeah I hope Freddie
could help us but so what does white
actually do how do you get these pieces
out so takes takes rook the one is
probably a mistake okay so kids who the
keep the rook on D to me yes if you just
do the he broke out of the game and also
kind of stalling for time mm-hmm so if
flag goes route k1 probably g3 is
already an idea develop let's say here
takes Bishop g2 everything's defended I
can take this and we're up upon for the
moment for the moment black is still
active I'm not saying that black
shouldn't be fine here but white is okay
as well it seems perfectly reasonable so
I feel that after king e2 f2 XC for now
we have to activate that bishop somehow
so we would go g3 and then Bishop g2 and
even if these pawns drop would you
consider that
like a big advantage for black um nearer
to a draw as long as my pieces are
developed I think I can lose both those
pawns and it should still be a draw this
f2 g3 and I guess white would eventually
probably play h4 setup it seems pretty
compact pretty unassailable from the
white point of view I think that
objectively white should be able to hold
mm-hmm this is the current position but
it's not as easy it's much easier to
look at it at home
and say that okay this position is fine
for white well it still is a big if that
whites gonna lose those two pawns so
that it's gonna take black some time to
capture those and white may even be able
to come up with something in the
meantime
actually I'm curious if what if I go
Bishop ea8 planning to go Bishop b5 uh
that seems like a reasonable plan
because I don't want to wait for you
going for g3 Bishop e2 maybe I have to
play f3 here and if you check me out
I'll play King f2 huh might run into
some stuff because my rook will bounce
back so here's a question Bishop takes
in b5 here mm interesting
maybe this is somewhat along the whites
plan huh and I'll just recapture on e4
and you're saying that these bonds I've
got a couple pawns my deep on might
actually start rolling up the board
pretty soon yeah I don't think it's too
early to play e5
I think I'm comfortable playing that
here okay probably well let's go the AA
survey and take everything take all the
puns okay and now let's see
it's simply d6 that's what I simply d6
simply d6
it's that easy chess is that easy all
right if we go Yasser once I feel yes or
twice let's go like all the pawns
okay we can yeah i might defend this one
I haven't decided yet okay maybe I'll
give you a check first with the ships
each at work just making sure all of my
pawns are under control Oh King e8 king
e8 I mean maybe you can push some pawns
on man I want to push my pawns I want to
push that pawn first in that pawn second
and I don't see black winning this game
yeah these these bonds are stronger this
Bishop is a good helper yeah in fact I
would almost I would prefer white here I
think like might actually run into some
danger he's not careful yeah eventually
you might sneak this rook over to the F
file yeah
well very interesting ideas for both
players I think this is still a game
that could get either way
I kind of expect some developments here
yeah interesting developments and var
still has to decide to play this kinky
tune if rook d1 is also still another
option that yes very seriously
considering it seems but flea doesn't
consider it for too long down in just 10
minutes on the clock
mm yeah that's how hard it is because
you have to be very very very cautious
and yet the white player even though
you're up a pawn you might get into
trouble because these pieces are just so
underdeveloped yeah well why don't we
let these players figure it out and take
a look at what's going on in the B group
for today we have Stephen Zurich
compared against Dennis K Drake Victor
Michael FC partying CS circus Otto Perez
am on Hambleton paired against a rhombic
Obion alexander fear compared against
jack schtum bully AK and then our key
matchup of the day a vet a Craig Orion
who lost in round one is paired against
Group B top seed Manuel Petrosian who
did win his first round and is probably
looking to extend his lead today and so
what's going on in this game well this
big Armenian derby yes it's actually
hilarious because there were many themes
in today's rounds yeah if you haven't
seen and we probably going to take a
look at later but there's two specially
cars in the a group oh and two very
similar English's in the B group namely
maybe these players are watching each
other yes probably with this
efore system and what actually shocked
me is that when you learn for Knights
openings the first thing you learn is
never put your Bishop on c5 right
because Knight takes e5 has happened in
the game takes d4 and i4q yeah and if
you would go here I might even go I [ __ ]
you again my goodness and this will get
worse and worse please stop working me
Dennis
I can't can't stop won't stop okay all
right so so in fact that's why Bishop b4
is considered
the main line that she would aim to get
this doubled structure and play against
it right so this is Bishop c5 is for
some reason flight here takes takes d4
it should be for D takes Knight takes
Queen a3 Queen h4 and I suspect computer
preparation from black yeah I think it
must be to play something like this as I
think any classical player from the 70s
and 80s would be seeing this move well
it depends if if they're in the 1770s I
think this is quite topical that's true
it's true
Viktor Korchnoi would have harsh words
but you know Viktor Korchnoi so we will
live it leave it at that
Who am I to argue with with the engine
overlords yes so probably takes takes
Bishop e7 here and g6 or King f8 it's a
better choice and probably eventually d6
and it's not that it's easy for buy to
get an advantage right it seems pretty
reasonable for black yes after cold h4
what's going on here Queen h4 and
crazytown yeah and about to have them so
g3 @ni g5 ah okay so wondering how black
wasn't going to lose a piece yes you
thought you're gonna win yeah on move 9
I just attacked the Queen the Queen will
move away I'll take your night just as
easy Knight g5 Queen e2 queenie for and
it's funny because right now the
computer is celebrating white yeah but
probably White's computer was stronger
and why it's computer was celebrating
after Bishop takes g5 oh and then takes
absolute and Gregorian Yvette's a
Gregorian is saying hello to your little
Queen Queen's in the trap
h1 and asking how is onna get out from
there so takes takes b6 castle which
should be seven between
- nice little little finesse there
that's there and just uh if you're a
subtle threat of checkmate
yes subtle map mate on d8 this is one of
those cool little checkmates you want to
get the classic Bishop and rook synergy
working together and it's Paul Morphy
showed yes all those years ago
so Petrosian for some reason when
castles instead
oh.nothing checkmate not very strange
decision but Bishop g2 takes and Grigory
undecided okay I'm committed to the idea
of taking your queen and actually patron
had no other choice than taking on f3
just takes on f3 take takes takes
because otherwise rook age one is coming
and there's nothing you can do about it
I agree so now we get a very interesting
imbalance here yeah it's a the two
bishops the exchange for the rook I'm
being told Bo Dennis you know news flash
breaking news Alexander fear may have
just blundered quite badly oh my god
against such action Billy accent why
don't we take a look oh no does see
what's going on in the beat see the
players there I'm looking over the board
mm-hmm it's going on so went back at
this position white already I mean still
had the bishop pair yes so nothing to
complain about
u6 was played more bishops more space
yes on the other hand is a closed
position so it's true
eventually these pawns might get
extremely weak in fact it's a double
attack yeah two pawns how it's a full
rookie one takes ah so you don't yes
so probably this was just a blunder of a
pawn takes before takes
I mean c7 if you collect the B for pawn
then you lose the e5 one and that will
be a big issue and as far as I can see
this is a fairly miserable yeah the
situation this one doesn't like so
pleasant especially just down upon now
down the pond with a terrible pawn
structure yeah absolutely
if you were playing with a black squared
bishop you'd love to have all your pawns
on the white squares uh yeah this is the
the classic rule and I definitely think
it applies here
so where did white go wrong how should
white have avoided um I mean thanks this
might have been another blunder on fear
Spartans which is sad because it means
that he's not in a great shape because
he wondered in his previous game against
Manappuram as well so in this position
he had a decent game with the two
bishops but played a little bit
carelessly with h4n would be one
probably had to defend this pawn and
also make sure that the e5 pawn is
protected
yeah it's slightly confusing that he
chose to just kind of undefended these
pieces well fear is a very ambitious
player yeah h4 is an ambitious move he's
saying okay I'm going to attack you
there 98
but then he plays rugby 1 and sometimes
well if you pull Karras it's fine to be
on both sides of the board but flank
on the King side and the Queen side and
it looks like we have a result in the
Aman Hamilton game okay so of course
this one looking very good for black
ended in a draw ah and this would be a
draw so Hamilton bounces back after his
unfortunate round one game against Jack
I believe so coming back to the jacket
on Baldy a game with Alex under fear the
big issue here was that white was kind
of
undecisive choosing plans right and it's
kind of bouncing back and forth yes h4
and then relay will be one probably
thinking that okay let's play b4 instead
but that suddenly turned into a blunder
of a pawn yeah no I had the pleasure of
commentating with the dorset Erica Shani
a few weeks ago on the protests League
and something she really talked about a
lot was how the players who really just
play simply keep all their pieces
defended are much less likely to fall
into these types of tactics and
especially for players of like I think a
higher caliber it's kind of easy to get
wrapped up and you know trying to play
so perfectly where you don't waste any
time defending all your all of your
pieces that's sometimes you just find
yourself falling for these tactics when
sometimes the best move is just to play
simply keep your pieces defended and
avoid these types of tricks and
shenanigans well in these strategic
positions you have to be very careful
what you do right because you won't
suffer the consequences immediately you
suffer five moves or ten moves later and
you see the apon marching down right
with a terrible structure with no hope
of surviving yeah it's very difficult so
strategy is not an easy game mm-hmm you
can get into trouble if you don't know
what you're doing but one advice would
be choose one plan and stick with it
yeah definitely that's important so with
that let's take a look at three Robson's
game sure how is Ray doing as switch is
getting switched is getting into time
trouble and he has eight minutes against
17 a very photogenic
streak of light across the board there
that we saw from the tournament hall so
great start from the opening so this was
actually assayed in two boards the
smearin fun for us game
had this position but here smear and
deviated with HD Robson played this
classical way of playing which is kind
of funny that when Laco was ascending
this room okay and challenging Kramnik
he used the Suresh Nico with great
success in Dortmund and he was battling
this specific position that Alec says
sheriff and history repeating itself yes
so we are just returning and it seems
that the time is going taking a
backwards so 94 Queen d2 the big issue
is that sometimes some sacrifices can
happen
not yet but II five and Bishop f5 was
played well for example if eight-six is
played then boom it's time for sacrifice
if you take obviously I take back and
I'm up a healthy pawn yes if you take
well you really don't want to hit that
because I'm swarming all over you spying
some danger here for black and this
position is very very very dicey yeah
rook takes f6 it has to be one of my
favorite moves in chess here it just
feels so satisfying it yes it it feels
like some crunchy bar that she just
found a very healthy bite of the blacks
King in blacks position yes
so Bishop f5 was played to avoid all
this massacre it was about to happen
rook e1 just bringing in all the heavy
artillery 8 6 9 f3 bouquet 8 h3 so bit
of waiting game which is not necessarily
a bad choice by me Robson because his
opponent is eating lots of time yeah and
veer on move 22 18 moves left and the
position is still complicated and
definitely this is one of the more
complex positions that we've seen today
they should be 7
probably queen f2 with queen g3 was an
idea but ray decided to take take and
exchange self and ID five probably he's
saying that the f7 pawn is way two weeks
I don't care about the Bishop there yeah
you really noticed this Bishop on h7
kind of not not pulling its weight there
definitely if I could pick one piece for
black to improve I would love to put
that guy on e6 for example where can at
least come back but the white Bishop to
be honest I'm not a big fan of taking on
f6 okay because I feel this Bishop is
way stronger than this one why would you
wanna get rid of your active Bishop well
I thought your passive Knight well I
think why it was looking at that Bishop
on age seven he takes off both the
Knights and then he immediately occupies
the d5 square really highlighting that
neither blacks minor pieces can ever
really attack that night can really ever
make it move and so I think that's what
White was thinking here is if you can
take off both these Knights and then he
has this nice advantage with this knight
on d5 controlling a lot of squares I
don't know I just had have the feeling
that if this Bishop activates things can
get ugly for white as well right so it's
getting double dashed here and Bishop g6
was a pretty good move defending this
pawn mm-hmm question is if we can play
on the tactical ideas of this g6 not
actually being protected
yeah there's tential discovered ideas
painting ideas here would each worth
work yeah actually not really because
Bishop III is I think this should be
three might be coming no matter what
here of course you can't take d4 again
yeah due to this Bishop III move yes so
here if Queen D for them Bishop e3 and
unfortunate things might happen you know
you don't no matter how no matter how
you take the bishop here yes going to be
losing a clean there so there's no good
positions that you can't mess up with
one move yeah and it looks like some
who's have actually been played King age
one was played getting out of this
there should be three idea Bishop III
was played it's probably queen g3 I
assume would happen king gate 7r king
edge it not second gate and is there any
way I can maneuver my knight to really
play against this bishop I mean I really
would like to get rid of this bishop uh
yeah but they don't I judge my true
statement and I think that that trade
might actually be favorable for me
though okay
because sonata for Bishop takes rook
takes and then I'm not sure what black
is actually intending to play here but I
have a few different that's I can play
something like Queen f3 and just triple
on the F pawn and I can play something
like out of Queen h4 as well
eyeing the agent for pawn Queen h4 ah
you're setting up a sly little trick
maybe nasty so here here if black is
unsuspecting there could be this nice
libel yet to capture it's actually
ending up in a draw because of Perpetual
but it's a nice little chick yeah
there's some definitely some problems
for black I mean now black does have a
perpetual well yeah but there's some
tactical ideas yes some tactical ideas
remaining so I'm not sure so spirit
seems to be under some pressure but I'm
not convinced okay because it seems that
black has enough to defend these pieces
yeah alright so let's take a look at
actually I think ray just played a move
I'm curious what he played Queen j-3
most Ouija three okay and so now we're
just expecting something like King h8
from so if something naive would have
happened Knight f6 of course and our
family is grown bigger and bigger
because this is the biggest family fork
I've seen this tournament it's it's a
pretty substantial one and after this
this position is going to be nasty as
rook f6
and I collect everything your whole
Queen side
your queen and the game I like wait in
this one like so black does have to have
some amount of caution here it looks
like young h7 was his choice do you have
some more news though from the people in
my ear I believe they think
Ilyas Mirren may be winning his game in
the a group that would be a big comeback
excuse me for Elias Marin as he lost a
an important game against receive do our
badly yeah we see the players there and
it looks like Jordan is is actually
under some some pressure yeah gene by
his body language yes
and those pawns look very devastating
yes dangerous stuff you can't even just
take because this pawn will just start
marching at it's overly like does have
this d3 pawn to try to compensate for it
but it's kind of meaningless if you
can't blockade these phones on the
queenside note these black pawns both of
them are terribly narrowly placed and
they're also kind of hard to defend yeah
I mean forest manages to defend it with
the rook at the moment but it's just
there by a thread so let's uh let's try
to break a blacks position here yeah so
I'm expecting Bishop d8 seems like the
only move that I can find to keep the
game going and so how do we break
through here well we would look around
for some jumps but also this seep on
this kind of weak right maybe something
like Rick a4 okay for but a might leave
your hand you're a pawn okay so let it
be a this guy's taken then you're okay
for there you okay for and if d2 then
just block it and it's going nowhere yes
but if you play rook d1 I take b5 that's
true I still will be up a pawn basically
because this C pawn is worth way more
than these so yeah understandable
but I'm not saying that this is
necessarily the best choice
but after white takes this pawn this can
also be considered a technical win for
white Zin but of course all these guns
will be extremely weak with this line in
mind I'm kind of tempted to just play
move like King f1 just such that black
doesn't really have White's black to
move though we're not in this position
I meant rather than playing rook 1/4
okay I just want to play this game like
King f1 keep things under control and
just bring the king gift b2 ever yes
mm-hmm
and yeah the difficult thing is for
black that you can't really get too
active because I have some nasty tricks
like this and the cancers they try to
break out here yes so this position
looks very very depressing for Jordan
yeah you got to think this should just
be a win for white YUM it doesn't even
have to do anything special just uh you
can play slow he can play quickly but uh
it all it all looks bad for black here's
and looks like we do Marin definitely
has a good chance of coming back looks
like we do have a couple moves played so
what did the players decide on so for
some reason it showed Queen e3 but I
should say five like take sticks and
this is obviously an improved version
because at least black has a blockade
yeah absolutely
the queen is is good at stopping points
so it makes sense to defend your guys
and then proceed from there yeah I would
tend to agree let's say Brooke the eight
could stop this d2 it okay - it's six
Aibileen oh I have some 87
yeah a seven maybe yeah I guess a seven
would be the way but to start there's no
reason to rush
it's basically black is trying to defend
a strategically hopeless position right
because eventually these pawns will fall
maybe black gets something he can hope
for something but I think objectively
this should be lost
oh yeah based on structure I tend to
agree but it does bother me that I can't
find a way to really break through
immediately here um
well sometimes you don't have to yeah
but I want to you know I know you want
to but you don't need to the best part
of the chess game is when it's over
that's true okay yeah I mean eventually
eventually so what I'm thinking yeah
that white eventually would build the
position could even go h4 h5 it feels
the need to sure but the plan would be
to go rogue d2 and Queenie for hassling
that pawn right and my problem is always
this b-pawn falls as soon as I as I move
my Queen away but that's a rook c8 but
if I but then this palm falls that's
true let's say if we wait around what
happens oh but now I have this nice
drink
ah yes rook b8 instead of 48 rook b8
but now I can go Queenie for okay
Queen a5 possibly I take the pawn I'll
take your beep you'll take my pawn how
dare you mean Queen takes and I try to
promote you succeed it looks I succeed
so yeah maybe yeah maybe this Queenie
for idea does eventually yes
come with too many threats for blocking
deal with I'm not saying that there are
no hopes for survival but the very
precise place Marin should be able to
convert right now alright so what do you
want to check out now let's go back to
the Akopian game yeah why not yeah a
game of the day how is this game
progressed last we checked in of course
yes var had a couple extra pawns
yeah but had some very serious
difficulties getting developed so we
left off around rook takes D 2 would be
1 then we were waiting for boobs and
what I decided to go rogue do you want
huh I do assume that he felt that King
gave Bishop e8 is just too dangerous
yeah it was a an interesting endgame but
so this Anna in a practical game it's
very tempting to avoid this right this
looks extremely extremely tough if you
just calculate something or flex your
get active it's it's done if the game is
over
rook takes 8 - and now the d5 pawn Falls
and this is kind of annoying
even though probably why should be able
to survive mmm castling doesn't really
work as far as I know especially des the
King moved it would work better if it
was legal would be better if it was
illegal so rook F 1 is a must if the
bishop moves f king D 2
but actually how is this endgame
probably why it is too active that would
be my instincts but you might know
better than I maybe I cook d5 Luke d5
oka King f6 Rick d6 and then Rick age
six yeah are you in there okay
well then I want to play Ricky six here
and take care but I might also have four
ideas okay I can be four but then I'll
check you a defendant okay not impressed
not impressed yet that would ruin the
fun just king d5 and get fine check me
again please rig age six well I think
I'm gonna go for that pawn I am my kings
getting driven away that's kind of
unfortunate yeah you might win that one
yes so okay so what what does weight do
so white should think activate the rook
should be pretty good
mmm-hmm and if the King has to move here
I would even considered this one and
just taking I can still take right sake
I know this is like something I was
hoping to to Jim but but this doesn't
really look too threatening for a wife
should be a job yeah this active rook I
think this should be a drop mm-hmm
definitely not a disappointing result
for the Seif here yeah you know he had
all the fun in this yeah he had all the
fun let's go back to the position
actually war played King d2 interesting
instead of
instead of rook f1 Calphalon so maybe
this is gaining some time yes Bishop b3
but this is kind of nasty because it's
hard to get out of it
yeah just rook e1 I thought I have okey
one that's true that we actually
transpose and the only difference that
in rook is not on not on f1 yeah but you
want more advantageous of course cuz
you're already hitting this this epon
yes but in fact maybe it was even better
to try to play for activity instead of
exchanging pieces yeah so we actually
saw Bishop b3 on the board and then bar
chose g3 trying to maybe keep all of his
pawn yet just seems like a reasonable
he's a little F way to play this it
could be Czech takes takes yeah but this
structure seems a lot like even less
promising than the previous one yeah
this active rook harassing these pawns
this pawn being guarded by the Jeep on
yes not not the easiest game to win yes
y can start maybe attacking then if the
King comes you can start repeating the
attack right and that should fizzle into
the draw okay so maybe some some
accurate play by bar there to escape
that one yes it's a nice escape by var
but probably a bigger success for
through our belly - yeah probably
putting on the the serious pressure here
with the black pieces so what is
happening in our other key matchup of
the day what has progressed in a
Gregorian petrosyan so a lot has
happened here we seem to have found
ourself in an endgame yes I would think
that white is winning this possibly seem
too strong again as we seen already many
games this pawn might run up the board
yeah it's it's it it's just going to
happen I think what does black even do
let's say c5 the only thing I'd be can
why it's like getting rid of all the
pawns yes if black could manage to sag
the rook for the pawn bishop and upon
Bishop and upon yes then possibly there
would be a chance for a draw I guess
you'd prefer to give this route for this
one and the black squared one so you can
go ahead and create that right technical
drawing and game so it might not be as
easy as it might seem well I'm a little
confused how black can achieve this
getting rid of a bishop and the pawn
it's very hard to stop this pawn it goes
fast but okay let me go here I guess you
just relax e7 or c7 yeah you cannot play
kt7 due to Bishop f5 mm-hmm yeah there
should be some was too strong yeah this
looks like a like game over to me so
let's take a look from here cuz here
Petrosian already had some play right he
has lots of pawns but these bishops are
just suffocating yes absolutely there's
lots of pressure on these pawns
controlling so many squares preventing
black clearly using his Rex effectively
a5 and probably c5 was the star move not
fearing ghosts especially because of
Bishop rook right so the main point
being that a vet tech needs that pawn to
win the game yeah it's very difficult
difficult actually to win this position
if you don't manage to get a passport
for white right so even though yeah I
mean kind of your two options are get a
passed pawn and promote to a queen or
somehow checkmate black but it's not
looking easy to check me yeah it doesn't
look likely with kind of King in the
center exposed right a 5c 5 c5 creating
a passe yes I think this was like golden
move check
during the rook takes Bishop d6 playing
for the strength of the position yeah
white is going to collect on these pawns
engage seven deciding to give up on that
Bishop takes f7 mm-hmm keeping the eye
on the prize say one thing that strikes
me as odd is I'm wondering how black
managed to get White's rook off the
board here something you know I've been
told about these types of end games is
that very often the two rooks can be
redundant they do a lot of the same jobs
whereas the rook for white can be a very
key piece in working with the
viciousness so not that like you know
White's position I think is totally
winning but uh as as black I would have
been very happy to get that trade in yes
because you do get closer and I think we
have some moves here in this position
but so yeah the rook exchange but I
think to be honest disposition is not
that easy to play for a white yes it
should be objectively winning right but
because of the reduced amount of pawns
for white it's very easy to mess it up
understandable and in fact here g6 would
have been stronger g6 move would have
been stronger I said yeah struggling
with the software yes so I said g6 would
be stronger mm-hmm
and there's some hope so black can try
and try to push the pawn somehow if you
can manage to get off that G pawns and
its chance that I'm drawing really
really go up yeah but on the other hand
this C pawn does have like a clear clear
route to victory
so King g8 was played Bishop d6 and
sadly for black it's just too easy for
white just to push it up and also notice
that the bishops also take these squares
from that central position yeah both
bishops can can stop either the a pond
in the H pond quite easily really
doesn't matter if black starts pushing
the ponds we will just exchange and
these bishops will stop them by not even
doing anything
yeah and just a note the two bishops
against the king does win the game yes
that checkmate why not not very hard as
the knight in Bishop well not as hard as
the knight in Bishop and you can be sure
that I bet a Gregorian will know how to
win that position right and I assume
that this will be a wind florica victory
gregoria a big son back he having lost
in round one this is a huge game for
Vedic it's also a huge game for the
tournament standings as a man well is
the number one seed in the Fall Classic
in the B group and after he won his
first game I'm sure he he was hoping for
a lot more today than was what he's
getting here so let's take a look at
dish then bully out game oh it looks
like we have a result between yes circus
out of Perez and Victor Nicholas yes it
ended in a draw
ah so not too shocking they're not I'm
shocking so what did you want to take a
look at Ashton bully akka Alexander for
your game their fears struggles can he
continues to struggle right while then
bullying it might go - at it - yeah 202
would be a fantastic way to start this
game this tournament and it seems that
the situation did not improve for white
it actually got worse and the software
still does not like me so we're just
going to continue from here the issue is
simple even if you exchange this d5 pawn
I'm just going to roll right pawn and
there's not much you can do probably I'm
gonna check you first and then rolled
upon something a white might try to do
is sacrifice this Bishop for this this a
pawn and try to find a way to take off
all of the Kings side pony
but unfortunately that doesn't really
seem realistic here sacrificing this
bishop for this pawn is actually going
to be quite difficult I think for my
sake
it's black to move yes and crush like to
move and crush
perhaps I should capture but you should
kappa promote to a clean myself and say
hello to the new lady the new ruler of
the board that'll get the job done this
is a no-go because this bishop is eyeing
that square mm-hmm and also sadly for
white you can give one check but not
just this promotion even if I would be
in trouble I could so just block it but
Bishop a5 it's with check and I get your
block everything is firmly in hand
yes sir rook d7 actually was played and
this looks very very good for black yeah
this this must be winning this must be
just a clear win but let's check in with
the Ray Robson game as time trouble is
looming with Robson pink Laurent time ah
so little turnaround there also I think
black is suddenly doing quite nicely in
this position ray it looks to be in some
serious trouble Missy this e pawn is
very frightening and this is what I said
that I didn't like and sometimes that's
why you listen to some classic players
like Fischer is saying that I love the
bishop there I would never want to give
it away right even though this Bishop
takes f6 seems like a normal move and it
does have a logic tracking that f7 pawn
it does come with the risk of those two
bishops eventually when you're breaking
free and breaking free and havoc
becoming powerful and now both of these
bishops work really hard yeah
King edge one Bishop III in G three King
eight seven we left it here we should be
three of us played f5 and for white I
was a bit scared of running out of ideas
oh yeah f5 seems like a nice idea from
black to bring this Bishop back to a
more relevant diagonal also no more f7
weaknesses it's true and this was kind
of the issue that this night does look
pretty on d5 it actually does not much
right and therefore I don't like Bishop
f6 idea and inside all right I guess
okay I guess you've got me there
but that's inside 20/20 and we're not
there yet so rook Queen f3 was played
rookie v rookie v defending this pawn
potentially preparing some ideas takes
takes in f4 came and having a protected
past pawn in the middle game that's
never a good sign
no no it isn't and potentially black my
just have an overwhelming advantage even
checking these pawns don't really
concern black because if I can play f3
either you watch me roll down with those
pawns or you just get simply checkmated
mm-hmm
da row is actually I wanted to mention
I'm sure you've had the pleasure of
playing many of these players and in
this event dar was the only one I've had
the pleasure of playing Oh or perhaps
the misfortune of playing it's
fortunately having been on the receiving
end of the the punishment for Nora he's
you know a very accurate player in my
experience yes so you know you give him
this this opportunity to reactivate his
pieces and he's not going to miss it I
think he's kind of a universal player
like he's there he has a very fine
understanding of positional chess right
but it is also a mean tactician yes I
agree and we see the players they're
hard at work so actually down to just a
minute in 50 seconds
yeah I'm sure trying to make something
out of this position
not wanting to let ray off the hook and
g3 was a good practical try right trying
to break free hoping that hopefully I
can muddy some waters before it's way
too late so you're trying to break free
now now I'm trying to okay we'll see
because I've got to break three okay
alright so yeah g3 trying to break up
these these two ponds
if takes I Asuma you would take here
that that would be a and because this
Bishop is still a little bit dumb
because of this pawn yeah I might get
away with this so I assume black
wouldn't want that but what can you do
so one option would be to gamble gamble
risking it all risking it all but at
least I would get active peace play
right I was interested in the movement
Queen c5 rather than a FIFA I got it
yeah also there's some tricks here as
well
Queen c5 mm-hmm and I want to play takes
Bishop h5 and somehow find some activity
this way and Queen B fibers is annoying
yeah because I exchanged the Queen's and
yes there's no way to get to get at your
king yeah in fact Queen a5 was an option
here Oh yet movie Queen a5 is a bit
better to attack and get the bishop ball
so the Queen that's what Darley actually
played I believe is five Queen 85 was
played to race choice maybe we should
stay here yeah all these plates are
rolling the time pressure rookie - lets
play - and then he just captures on g3
yeah Wow and that makes a lot of sense
rookie three would run into this
terrible terrible Queen d2 whoo whoo
winning the whole house and a bet that's
enough for me
Queen g3 but then I can defend this pawn
this looks oh whoa okay I can't
I can't play Queen d2 I wanted to play
Queen d2 okay let's I can't
there's just c3 in the end and yeah
there's unfortunately this bishop will
take control of this square it would
have been nice
yeah one of them very no Queen d2 for me
but Queen c5 is the slow position very
Russian approach okay from Jeter don't
have Queen c6 stuff oh then there's this
idea of Bishop f7 ah very sneaky stuff
very sneaky stuff and if takes then I
guess the king will have a little bit of
a walk and just block this pawn what if
Bishop f7 can i play e to Bishop f7 e -
hmm it's a bit much but it's like a try
you just take on g6 and take my rug I
have known oh yeah and I covered this
square ah it's very sad and none of my
tactics are working so probably clean c5
and some Queen f5 is better avoiding
some trickeries right but you can expect
some turnarounds here mm-hmm
it's not I'm killed for so what's a rain
going to do here it's still his
tournament I think he will try that one
I think he's going to go there and try
to well you've got me wondering about it
was like Bishop f7 in the first place
yeah really so pivotal that we take this
Jeep on off the board yes but Swedes
decided to go Queen h5 okay the idea
being I want to harass this rook so if
you go here then your quickest Queen is
stuck there forever you move the rook
I've pushed the pawn but I do love
offering Queen trades so what if I were
to play Queen G for green g4 okay that
was race choice good hmm how do you
progress with white here there black
brother I definitely wouldn't want to
exchange Queens feels like there should
be something going on so but now I think
sure this fiend queenie 5 or queen c5 I
think probably queenie 5 makes more
sense because now after there's there's
no roof g2 yeah nonsense as well you're
also covering the g7 square it's my
point
oh yeah that's that's a good point I can
go Bishop by 5 root G - yeah Bishop f5
Bishop h5 I really want to get on the
same diagonal as this king yes man
notice that this is also big issue yes
of course
and Queen e5 was played I think daro is
on the road Queen h5 is a very nice nice
move then drawing this Queen under the
suburbs Square on G drawing it to white
squares yeah
and then bring the Queen in the center
basically double attacking a lot of
finesse from the place this also looks I
see yeah I think Darla might define
found a very convincing way here yes
well so ray under seconds see a ray just
played rook e1 it looks like and the
last possible moment
no Amy shaking his head - she's unhappy
yes he's looking at the wall you can
tell this is not what he wanted to look
at fate look after - we still have the e
pawn and the attack yeah that should be
deadly this this does not look like it
badly so Wow dar really navigating the
the time pressure they're a bit better
than Ray Ray was already under some
pressure to begin with but some some
very nice moves from daro here so maybe
if the pressure on in the critical
moments yeah I think dar was defending
really well and he had to but I think
Robson did have the advantage
it's a moment but then over pressed a
little bit with giving away the bishop
yeah and if he would have kept a bishop
on and going like Queen after Queen G
three attacks probably he would have
some slight pressure not saying he would
win or anything like that I'm saying
that probably after they reached this
position with the knight on d5
practically doing nothing yeah um that's
the moment when Ray's where trouble
things started going wrong yeah and it's
much easier to play this position with
black to be honest yeah f5 is a very
nice smooth and yeah after that a lot of
his problems seem to be solved yes and
this position is already in very
precarious mm-hmm Daario taking his time
here though trying to find the correct
way to finish finish the game here and
what's the doesn't want to take too much
time otherwise all those I'm watching
these games looking for how to be good
at technical games when you're winning
you're still supposed to take some time
to figure out the ultimate and the best
way of winning the position right so the
reason why switz is still taking up some
time is that he's looking for the best
possible way to finish and wrap it up
and he does choose Bishop h5 this should
be almost his final seconds I believe
yes I think around 20 seconds yeah
something like that
Bishop h5 but in fact rook f8 would have
been a little bit more thematic I think
but Bishop H value is a very human move
well I think you're probably going to
play both moves no matter what yeah
Bishop h5 and then no matter where the
Queen goes oh well Queen e4 is is it did
give this chance of bailing yeah at
least getting rid of the Queen's
although this is still gonna get pushed
right and this should still be very hard
to defend for white so Rick takes e4
played rookie for plate White's hope is
that somehow he could try to put some
pressure on the e pawn mm-hmm but it's
not that easy because black might just
go rookie v g5 and how are you gonna
ever approach that pawn yeah the King is
a little bit stuck in a box yes
it's boxed and it's in this little box
and the good news for black is this King
is not boxed in so uh that's like King
g2 playing with an extra piece a g5 c3
not gonna fall for this one ah very
tricky very tricky and white is just
waiting for black to improve the
position and just win right
so Bishop d5 was played instead you know
simply rookie 7 finding that b7 was
played and sadly for white there's
really not much you can do against just
slowly maneuvering forward but let's see
how Swedes does it mm-hmm
I didn't want to mention it looks like a
the game between Alexander fear and
juliek is just about to wrap up here I
did not manage to take off the potty in
the Kings I assume what actually seems
to have lost more pawns on the king I
assume the epoch makes they actually do
see the hand shake and she'll hear a
pong that made the home run yeah it
seems the stellar a pawn winning the
gayest we've seen players signing the
score sheets this brings Jack to a
stellar two out of two to start off this
tournament albert hubbed jack you have
the two out of two definitely the way
you want to start this one off this is
just a single round-robin of course yes
so there are only nine rounds so two out
of two is is already a lot of the way
there plus two of those very decent
score a lot of points and also big score
with black yeah and of course have the
white pieces next round I believe and a
big chance to make it three out of three
yeah we'll have to keep an eye on his
games going forward yeah here we see ray
and daro back again any other
interesting games going on as we're in
this time pressure area so smearin is
about to wrap it up as well mm-hmm he's
up a pond and probably another pond is
going to fall interesting so yeah Ilia
of course had that very nice position
against jordan earlier on and now he's
kind of gone into just a simplified Rick
and Gaia he's just gonna Lex yeah the
sheep on this spawn should still win the
game he cashed in his chips but luckily
he made quite a profit there so yeah
here we see the tournament he's actually
he's wandering around yeah game firmly
and hint yes let's take a look at
Lenderman game we haven't seen too much
of his games yes and so Malcolm II and
of course one of the players tied for
the lead in the a group and he's
actually pushing a little bit as he has
the better structure also he's probably
go here and collect that palm mm-hm
of course this is an extra pond for
black though yes that's true but after
collecting that pond on on c6 of course
yes there are some small weaknesses not
too terrible for Lenderman but might
have some slight issues yeah what we do
have current and group a leader Jack
shouldn't bully AK ready to come into
the studio here so I'll let you analyze
your game of choice while I step out of
the chair here and get him into the
studio all right so let's take a look
how three Gurion is making work and as
we can see nothing really changed much
that see pond is still roaming down the
board angrily this pond is still
unstoppable vg5 takes and there is no
stopping of the cheap on in fact there's
some cute tactics here c6 is winning
takes c7 and as we've seen something
very similar in Jack stumble the eggs
game the pawn and the bishop is a good
combination together and sometimes it
makes your day so that's say hello to
Jack Stan boolean congratulations thank
you this is not the first time we've met
let me just pull up your game okay
so can you get us through to the through
the key moments of your game today
mm-hmm yeah sure so at the beginning
mm-hmm
maybe a couple of months before okay
like here yeah I wasn't sure what to
play because if I go 98 he plays d4 so I
came up with a interesting icing idea of
Brook shade preventing d4 yeah here I
guess just to show then you'll have some
nice jumps and that'd be nice
yeah okay yeah and here he played h3
which is pretty logical 98 494 hm
yeah and here he played Bishop of 2
which I didn't really expect yeah I kind
of feel that he was hesitant he didn't
seem too familiar with the position did
he take a lot of time in the game I mean
not really
I mean he took quite some time but not a
lot and here but but I think the shuffle
is very interesting like his idea was
very interesting like yeah because first
of all I started bishop of to the bad
move because I simply take on it too and
he takes Queen eat or play 97 and I'm
threatening 96 and if he plays are fives
and I have b5 more mm okay yes yeah so
like I was really happy with my position
but then he played a 5-2 moves that I
didn't calculate yeah and here after 96
he played a 5 yeah and here's positions
very interesting I'm not sure about the
evaluation but probably I should be fine
but it's not it's not very easy so what
plans did you consider here so I decided
not to take only 5 right away mhm
because it seemed dangerous yeah because
he just takes by icons in place 95 after
Bishop 6 and yeah and you're under some
constant pressure you can never open
because this is loose no we decided to
go Bishop c6 yes he has 5 months up to 6
first d5
95 and here
yeah I - this wasn't a happy decision I
assume yeah I mean here he probably he
probably should have played she takes d5
I'm not sure but I think it was
interesting and after 94 just taken t4
and I said this should be slightly
better for you because he has like
potentially better Bishop yeah because
let's say if he wins d4 pawn somehow and
then placed before himself
then my bishop and you sound would be
dead yeah yeah that's why I had
calculated he finds a moment yeah but
after Bishop g5 his position is still
fine mm-hmm community 7 and here I
didn't expect h4 mm-hmm yeah or it
doesn't seem to make much sense yeah
yeah I mean it's just a waste of time
yeah because after h4 I'm probably
already better so instead he probably
should have taken on d6 mm-hmm yeah I
would take with a pawn and here I
thought if he takes only 6 yeah from the
first side it looks like Bishop enough
to is much worse than the bishop on g7
but if he takes on e6 I wasn't really
sure what to take risk because if I take
with the Queen he can take on his six
and want eggs and if he manages to
promote B force and his bishop enough to
his brothers on g7 so I thought maybe
like rook a4 even after obi-wan there
was a very interesting idea of playing
something like b5 maybe and b-58 takes
before 6 was an a5 I wasn't sure about
it just taking away that yeah Thunder
okay 8 and Ruby
okay so probably eat X was better yeah
maybe even leaving the tension just
maybe doing just smaller yeah better
also it's putting the pawn on the same
square as this Bishop mm-hmm so that
could be a little issue but okay an idea
yeah an idea and now he realized that he
has some problems here because like I
have a very simple plan if I play ecigs
and 96 through cavity 8 and then just we
yeah like exchange pawns in the center
his position is just worse yeah yeah
that's why here we had tried to like
find some counter play - make it double
it but I mean he it just didn't work
yeah it just didn't work like you
probably missed some quick moves so you
just won the pawn yeah here he probably
means that yeah yeah that this is a
double attack yeah so this was a very
clean when it seemed I mean from here on
on yeah
but later I wasn't sure about my
decision like first of all I what moment
when I played be 6p6 can you point here
yeah here I was really sure cuz
initially I wanted to take on c4 then
Queen takes rook takes rook takes b7 and
I was gonna go okay it's ER uh-huh but
then I realize that after he plays
Bishop III it's not it's not so easy
here no no Ruby said okay and then we
should be and then Bishop III yeah and
now I cannot put my bishop on e6 and now
he has some rope 180s so now it's not
that easy
yeah that's why I took some time and
play b6
hmm so just to get a better version of
that yeah here I thought you should go
away crook c1 or something but yeah he
won't be six and now I got motherboard
yeah you got everything and this was
basically a technical women yeah and
here it was the last chance for him like
if he trades rooks then it's completely
winning for me yeah so that's why he had
to go with g5
he takes d5 ecigs and of course the
position here is losing that at least
kick ass like some shutters some active
pieces and some practical yeah maybe
like so much five eight years yeah but
after here it was fairly standard yeah
here I just you have everything that you
dream of that Bishop kind of entombed by
its own pawns
yeah so great win for you
yeah Cinco two out of two good start
we do have next actually ideally check
it okay so I'm trying to play like round
by round round by round yeah
professional never heard that before and
what are your expectations for this
tournament Oh actually I'm gonna play a
world championship under 20 October so
this is like a very good preparation for
me and what seed are you approximately
in world and world champion yes for now
it's like it's it ten mm-hmm yeah so
it's a good afternoon
yeah it's a good warm-up and you're
doing great so good luck for the next
round yeah thank you good luck and let's
take let's take a look at what happened
since in the Robson dario's game and
exactly what we predicted with Caleb
white is basically just like in the
previous game this king just like the
bishop and the stamboli our game is
entombed can't really escape from this
box and it's just waiting its eventual
doom to arise disastrous for Rob's and
this is disastrous for Rey white can
stall and just make random moves but I
think this is eventually collapsing yeah
this this doesn't look very comfortable
at all yes so one idea for white may be
to try to play something like c4 and b4
and b5 and create a passed pawn
mmm-hmm what is as black fast enough to
do something in this regard um I'm sure
I need to be fast because at any moment
I can go eat too and I don't really
think that before before there we go all
right B 5 B 5 okay I do see that if eat
so you want to go can get to yes some
sorts please we must I really would like
to get my king over mm-hm
but okay like exchanging is never too
bad if you're off a pond okay I will
capture I take it and I will capture
again on a six capture back and C 5 C 5
hopefully I'm not wandering my I'm
blundering my pond I'm so sad
rookie 5 and I take yeah mm-hmm and this
just in our key matchup in the a group
between var Cobian and of a sifter
volley it's actually ended in a draw so
it what we expected from there yes it it
was all that we expected down to King
versus King yes we knew that it's going
to be a draw mm-hmm even though Akopian
is down upon it's not really enough for
a win for black because the king is
optimally placed right in front of this
pawn also this rookie is active enough
to harass this King and all those black
pawns absolutely so King g5 just staying
active and that's just what war did
mm-hmm
rookie 6 now eventually this pawn false
and that's just going to be the end
and the game ended in a draw some
accurate play there by both sides yes
so in our closing minutes here any other
games you want to really get a look at
anything looks super interesting not
really I think the big deal was the
Gregorian potential gregorian bin he
didn't win yet flee but he's on the road
to win this endgame why don't you check
back in with him and see that let's do
that he's really taking his time here
pushing this pawn I wanted to push it to
c7 like one minute I saw it yeah I use
being very responsible yeah you know
when you a couple when you drive and
then you have your nursing and advantage
be responsible of course okay Jade
Bishop h2 no funny business
not long now I'm gonna push my pawn
check I'll go back what are you planning
to go do next it's it's fairly unclear
yes
it's very hard maybe pushing but again I
just push and go go go go but it's too
late this and I just promote all the
lines seem to be working out in in
White's favor here yeah so probably one
of the biggest results in this
tournament was Istanbul the X win with a
black against lux under fear big upset
is a vet ik beating Manuel as he's
coming back after rebounding after a
loss and he's probably getting back into
the tournament yeah why don't we check
in with the final game going on there I
think they're just two remaining between
Steve and Zurich and Dennis Kendrick
rather even position black has a little
bit more active pieces but there are
some pressure on the e5 pawn and not
enough material left to actually have a
different result that than a draw
understand
I would assume a draw is likely here
yeah a draw here would of course bring
Stephen up to one and a half
yes placing him in second place behind a
gem Jack stumble there who is shaping up
to be the only player with two out of
two in the B group despite the
opportunity for as many as I think four
or five I think actually five it's
interesting all of the one-point players
played all the zero point players today
in the so yeah this pollution shaping up
to be a draw we see f4 on the board
really trying to I guess liquidate down
yes as quickly as possible no more
nonsense yes I let's go home yes I do
not think that objectively there should
be anything else but a draw right and
meanwhile checking in the Landry man
game the Malcolm Ian Lenderman game this
is kind of even but Malcolm Yan has the
moral right to push for the advantage as
these pawns are still a little bit
loosey-goosey
if the King could run over and maybe the
bishop could move away there's some
chances but objectively probably is
going to end in a draw right and that
would actually mean that if Dario's wins
the game he would either join the league
place with received our belly and
Malcolm young rose he also on his first
game against the Turkish Grand Master
Lex under a pot of okay so maybe we
should just keep an eye on that daro
game then that really seems like the
critical game still up in the air
whether or not daro can win this
position
so yeah what's going on here ray decided
to in fact push some of these pawns for
it it looks like you followed your
advice yeah just trying to find some
counter place somewhere on the board but
I do think that this can get 4g4 or
let's say okay let's choose a different
plan
how does this plan would shape up to do
so maybe this plan is good my question
was okay so you - there's always King F
- but yeah I'm sorry
so you've got me there but there's some
way I can play king e5 here King ePHI
letting your king out of the box - I
might yeah you do let my king out then
you don't want to do that he takes me in
that's true that's that's a truth
statement right there mmm it's tough to
suggest stuff for white because it's
lost in many ways I think all of these
positions are lost it depends which one
is the technically the best choice right
it's probably an interesting idea to
just go this Bishop g6 yeah to be frank
very technical definitely if you can
avoid letting the White King out yes
that's the way to go and with this
strong pawn and some pawns might even
fall in the future I think it would be a
huge miracle by Ray to survive this game
alright so why don't we take a look at
the standings that we expected to uh to
have leaving this ground the a group of
course is you know a lot of interesting
games happen today
leaving us with one possibly two or even
three co-leaders after the round today
definitely expecting Malcolm Ian to draw
his game bring him into shared first
with the Seif and Gregorian just want we
do have a result there and that's a big
comeback for abetik yeah absolutely
after losing in round one to win here
put some
on a level score not at all far behind
ya
top of the pack yes so I think the egg
group is getting tighter yeah definitely
we're gonna see lots of lots of exciting
games they're coming up and the B group
we have Jack running away he's running
the show so 200 already clear first just
two rounds into the tournament
it's a great spot to be in but two out
of two it's not on end of the world and
the show must go on do you think we
might see some surprises see what the
show has in store for us well before we
wrap up here we did want to include a
quick message from Ryan Chester with a
very exciting offer about the golden
tickets hi my name is Ryan Chester and
I'm the development manager for the
Saint Louis chess club I'm here to tell
everyone about a golden opportunity that
we have right now we're selling golden
tickets for $50 a piece it's a 50-50
raffle $5,000 will go to the Scholastic
chess initiative for the st. Louis chess
club and $5,000 will go to a lucky
winner we're only selling 200 of these
and we've already sold many to
grandmasters and all of our commentary
team as well so if you're interested
please call the Chess Club or go to our
website on the homepage and buy a golden
ticket there thank you and good luck
all right exciting stuff with the golden
ticket a quick side note they're
actually just 50 golden tickets left no
longer the 200 that we started out with
and the good news is you viewers online
are welcome to purchase those as well
you do not have to be present at the
golf tournament where the tickets will
be drawn in order to win so you can buy
and remotely you don't even have to show
up and you could win $5,000 once again
time is running out though dentists
those tickets are going to be drawn wait
too long exactly they're going to be
John run out of time September 30th and
who knows we might sell out before then
so definitely now is the time to buy
your rights get in that raffle get in
there and get your tickets well why
don't we take a look at the results in
the a grift
let's take a look we see ray raphson
still in progress against Darras roots
we're expecting Darwin really press yes
he's probably going to win that game
yeah a lot of faith in him Elias Miren
of course just wrapping up against
Jordan run Forrest
yes so though I see that Forrest is kind
of untangling interesting so maybe some
chess left to beady-eyed there alexander
Bortnick versus alex epitaph was
actually the first game to finish today
ending in a reasonably quick draw front
malcolm yin one of the tournament
co-leaders coming into today is still
fighting against Alex Linderman we're
expecting a draw there
and the game of the day yep
where it says dry barely ended in a draw
Vera Cobian had to eat the draw yes
somehow the most comfortable draw ever
but buddy he managed yeah both of them
are still in contention and for the
title and why don't we check out the
results in the B group Steven Zurich
still playing against Dennis Cade Rick
definitely expecting a draw from them
Victor mihailovski drew his game against
Quesada Perez I'm on Hamilton drew
against Iran Haku bein on the scoreboard
it's back on the scoreboard
still battling that illness I guess but
did manage to score I have been you're
on the scoreboard things are looking up
for yes once you get that first half
point the rest is easy Z from there yes
smooth sailing and of course Jack schtum
buyuk is the
of the day winning his game against
Alexander fear moving into clear first
with a perfect score of two out of two
who and then in the key matchup the top
seed of the tournament Manuel petrosyan
did not manage to get it done lost to a
vet Achra Gorian Ligurian pulled out
this fantastic upset and also a big
comeback for him after losing the first
game of the tournament yeah well that is
about it from us here in Studio B at the
st. Louis chess club you are welcome to
follow along on us chess chants calm the
games are still going on you're welcome
to watch them to conclusion but other
than that Dennis what an exciting round
today yeah it was brilliant moving
forward for round three yeah almost
matching that five just decisive results
in round one these players are brilliant
around clearly here to fight it out be
sure to join us tomorrow at the same
exact time 3:30 p.m. for round three
coverage of the 2019 fall chess classic
be there
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you